how do we make
thinking long term particularly about
these
long interval events how do we make this
natural how do we make this
something that not just some
elite people are doing but it's a
cultural thing it's something that's
embedded and people kind of do it's kind
of a literacy do you have any ideas
about
um if we can do that
and if so how do you think we could
it's a form of empathy in some way right
i mean
it's a type of i think bina was talking
about it as
an empathy with your future self and
with future generations and so
i know that you think a lot about
empathy and so
how do do do do you can you imagine
a society in the future where
this becomes the a natural thing to do
or is this something we always have to
work at
um well you know it's interesting
um i i do think it's
um on one level it's counterintuitive
for i mean it's it's it's it's not
something that humans do naturally as
we've been talking about that
you if you're trying to figure out where
you're going to get your next meal the
last thing you're going to be thinking
about is your long-term future
on the other hand i think that thinking
long term is
um is the way that um
people you know people have always made
meaning
um and so when you first asked that
question i didn't think ahead
i thought back i started to think about
you know i was thinking about
indigenous peoples and the you know
seven generations and
you know i was thinking about the way my
the way my
own imagination about the long term
got engaged first was
was in understanding my family
history and
and i think that that because when
you're young it's really hard
i think in some ways it's hard to think
you'll ever get older that
you know it's hard to so it's easier to
think longer term
the more you get older because you have
more you have more
um experience uh and so
i mean when i think about what what
one of the reasons i love thinking about
the long term is that
and and being in involved with long now
is that it's a
um it's a way of orienting myself
and um and and having horizons of time
that
that i won't see you know over that
horizon but but
being engaged with um connected to the
generations before and connected to the
generations after
is gives my life meaning